[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal préparé par la rédaction de tv
60,18 les titres de ce mardi 30 octobre
une quarantaine d'enfants aux yvelinois
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ils ont tout
récemment participé à une journée autour
du bmx découverte du sport et rencontre
avec le champion romand racines une
initiative solidaire organisée chaque
année par le secours populaire
sa construction a été achevée en 1993 le
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines a reçu son créateur
l'architecte stanislas fisher une
conférence visite sur l'édifice bâtiment
emblématique de l'agglomération enfin
demain c'est halloween les yvelines
auront plus d'une occasion pour se parer
de leurs plus beaux costumes nous vous
livrons dans ce journal
une sélection d'activités à faire à
saint quentin en yvelines et dans les
villes alentour un champion présents
pour répondre à toutes leurs questions
environ à 40 enfants puis découvrir
l'univers du bmx au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines une
animation proposée tout récemment par le
secours populaire du département le
sujet de mélanie poker et de patrick
jacques de dixmude
non parce que le vélo normal il va être
trop grand romain racines et double
champion de france junior de bmx
face à lui des enfants qui découvrent la
discipline c'est transmettre une passion
que certains
certains n'ont pas forcément la chance
d'avoir
moi je fais du vélo tous les jours et
c'est un plaisir on leur présente
directement une journée type d'un
athlète
comment il vit ici au centre et quelle
est sa discipline et qu'est ce qu'il
doit faire
et qu'est-ce qu'il fait pendant ces
entraînements c'est 35 enfants ont vécu
une journée autour du cyclisme
ils ont pu visiter le vélodrome assister
à des entraînements mais aussi se tester
le matin ils ont fait leur baptême de
bmx s'est pas trop trop facile mais ça
va je me suis blessé deux fois et après
c'était bien celle j'ai appris des
choses sur un ongle inique pour août et
où l'objectif de cela joli site est de
permettre à des enfants qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de pouvoir avoir accès aux
loisirs au sport d'avoir une journée
détente pendant les vacances et donc en
partenariat avec le vélodrome
la salle saint quentin en yvelines et la
communauté d'agglo de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de pouvoir
alors permettre d'avoir une initiation
de baptême de bmx en fait une mission
bien x une visite du vélodrome
chaque année le secours populaire fait
découvrir la discipline à des enfants
yvelinois issus de milieux modestes
une découverte du sport comme moyen de
réduire les inégalités et pourquoi pas
susciter des vocations
autre action solidaire celle du lion's
club de montigny est les trois villages
ce week-end l'association organisait sa
16e édition darmanin un marché d'art
contemporain au profit de plusieurs
associations les précisions avec ce
sujet de marylène iapichino et de manon
varaldo le marché de l'art contemporain
avisé solidaire harman et a fait sa 16e
édition
les bénéfices de la manifestation sont
entièrement reversées à des actions
caritatives
cette année la maltraitance le handicap
et la maladie d'alzheimer nous avons
remis un chèque de 1
mille euros pour des centres de vacances
et d'accueil de jour pour les personnes
atteintes de la maladie d'alzheimer mais
aussi pour les aidants peintres
sculpteurs photographes
harman et regroupe des artistes
d'horizons différents tous viennent
chercher un contact et un échange avec
le public
c'est toujours intéressant d'avoir des
opinions des idées c'est plaisant j'aime
lui même la preuve c'est des portraits
animaliers
humain j'aime les changes j'aime là et
c'est ce que je recherche sur des lieux
comme ça arman est devenu un véritable
rendez-vous christophe baudin est
artiste peintre
il vient à montigny depuis dix ans
chaque année il ya des nouveautés
j'ai mes clients fidèles qui reviennent
et qui viennent voir les nouveautés qui
qui revient voir mon travail
régulièrement
voilà donc je suis un habitué et j'ai
aussi mes habitués au total ce sont 40
artistes qui se sont réunis 12 20 %
venaient pour la première fois la 26e
édition du salon euronaval s'est achevée
à paris le bourget plusieurs secteurs la
défense est la sûreté maritime et la
sécurité 33 pays et à 470 exposants dont
des entreprises des yvelines reportage
sur place de nicolas landry c'est le
fournisseur de l'armée française et il
est yvelinois le groupe nexter basés à
satory participent à la fabrication des
engins de l'armée de terre il fournit
aussi les munitions de la marine
nationale pour eux navale il vient
présenter sa nouveauté le rapid fire une
tourelle équipé d'un canon télescoper de
40 millimètres fabriqué avec
l'entreprise thalès et b à e systems
destinés aux navires et à la une le
problème de la piraterie
le problème des drones aujourd'hui c'est
ces bâtiments sont attaqués par les
zodiac et pour répondre à ces menaces
ces menaces asymétriques on a besoin
d'avoir des canons de ce type là qui
permette véritablement de cibler et de
protéger les navires de guerre mais
surtout les navires de logistique de
l'armée française avec atos aux
clayes-sous-bois thales à elancourt ou
encore airbus saint quentin en yvelines
est représenté dans le domaine naval le
géant européen de l'aéronautique possède
notamment des services d'imagerie
satellite conçu en partie sur le site
élan courtois est une activité autour de
l'imagerie satellite qui permet d'aller
dans des zones éloignées regarder ce qui
se passe détecté de la pollution de
détecter des problèmes de trafic
le transport de drogue
lisa illégal est détectée très très
rapidement et on peut très bien à partir
des images satellites à les observer
quelque part une zone à côté des grands
groupes il ya aussi des pme comme sierra
packaging basée à buc avec deux millions
de chiffre d'affaires par an cette
entreprise est spécialisée dans la
découpe de mousse pour le transport
d'armes de radio ou de matériel
électronique de l'armée française n'a
mis deux types de mousses une qui est
basse densité pour venir absorber les
vibrations une qui haute densité pour
venir protéger la maquette les
contraintes du client on a besoin de les
comprendre pour savoir si c'est lourd 6
a besoin d'avoir une mousse anti
statique 6 a besoin d'avoir une mousse
retardant au feu et en fait on vient
usines et tout sur place on a notre
stock de mussig en usine tout avec
euronaval une opportunité pour ces
entreprises de rencontrer de nouveaux
partenaires
l'industrie navale de défense représente
près de 45 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires dans le monde
le sport en bref et cette mauvaise
nouvelle pour l'open de france de golf
nous l'avons appris hier ce tournoi
comptant pour le tour européen et se
joint à saint-quentin-en-yvelines perd
son statut de rolex series en clair
l'open devient une compétition de second
plan avec moins de dotations entre 2 et
4 millions de dollars contre 7
auparavant et décision motivée par la
perte du sponsor principal du tournoi le
groupe chinois à chennai autre nouveauté
l'open de france 2010 9 et déplacés de
l'été à l'automne il se jouera du 17 au
20 octobre toujours au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un bâtiment emblématique symbole
de la fin de l'édification de la ville
nouvelle le théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines était achevée en
1993 oeuvre de stanislas fischer est
l'architecte a été reçue pour une visite
conférence au sein de sa création elle
nous avons pu suivre ce rendez vous
suivi par de nombreux curieux le récit
de nicolas dans glee c'est une véritable
forteresse culturel le poumon artistique
de saint quentin en yvelines
inauguré en 1993 cette bâtisse a été
pensé par cet homme
stanislas fischer architecte à l'origine
de nombreux aménagements dans les villes
nouvelles et notamment plusieurs
théâtres nationaux
la juxtaposition de
de la technique technologies comme les
camps de la grande rampe la grande rampe
qui est que nous n'oublions pas une rame
qui devrait servir pour
pouvoir jouer les spectacles sous la
place les postes des statuts qu'on ne
peut plus les statuts sont pas arrivés
c'est génial qu'on attend toulouse et
statut dans le cadre de la journée
nationale de l'architecturé stanislas
fischer est revenu sur les secrets de la
construction du théâtre national
un bâtiment au coeur de saint quentin en
yvelines il est vraiment pensé pour être
un monument c'est à dire un point de
repère dans la ville quelque chose qui
reste qui est dans la durée et que tout
le monde reconnaît qui marque vraiment
le paysage s'était habillée en cat et
moi je vis et moi je partirai était
achevé sa photo bonheur c'était beau
d'elle même comme solution il estime à
bout aucune ride à signaler malgré ses
25 ans le théâtre national a encore de
belles années artistique devant lui en
conservant éternellement dans ses
travées l'adn de stanislas fischer
demain mercredi les yvelinois vont
trembler avec la fête d'halloween on
pourra voir notamment quelques
citrouilles comme sur ce plateau d'on
soir manon barral d'eau or ce n'est pas
vous la citrouille je vous rassure vous
en avez apporté une en plateau la
citrouille c'est le thème de votre
première idée d'animation à faire demain
car qui dit halloween dit forcément
citrouille et oui elles sont
indispensables pour cette fête qu'elle
fasse peur ou sourire les citrouilles
décor chaque année les maisons il enfin
les sculpte pour décorer le jardin ou
récolter des bonbons aux fermes de gally
les ateliers sont proposés aux enfants
de 3 à 12 ans pour creuser sa citrouille
jack o lantern
si vous n'avez pas encore votre
citrouille grégory pas d'inquiétude les
fermes de gally propose des ateliers
jusqu'à demain mercredi
ça se passe de 10h30 à 12h et de 14h à
17h30 vous pouvez acheter vos tickets
sur place à la ferme mais halloween ce
n'est pas que pour les enfants non en
soirée c'est au tour des plus grandes
avoir peur une murder party est
organisée à voisins le bretonneux un
crime a eu lieu dans la salle de la tour
le service jeunesse et prévention en
partenariat avec harmonie magic invite
les participants à résoudre la faire
grâce à des indices qu'ils devront
récolter sur place ils seront plongés 2
19h à 21h30 dans la peau d'un enquêteur
de police pour résoudre cette sombre
histoire
une animation qui sera mené par une
équipe de comédiens professionnels et
cette enquête à la salle de la tour est
gratuite on peut faire la fête le 31
manon m et des activités sont également
proposés le lendemain jeudi 1er novembre
oui pour les plus sportifs vous pouvez
participer autres halloween la deuxième
édition du challenge organisé par
l'association da doo ron ron se
déroulera le jeudi 1er novembre à 9h aux
clayes-sous-bois le départ sera donné au
parc jean carillon il avait rassemblé
plus de 400 coureurs l'année dernière
avec des courses de 10 et 19 km et une
marche nordique de 10 km vous pouvez
toujours vous inscrire sachez qu'un euro
par inscription sera reversée à imagine
fort margot une association qui oeuvre
auprès des enfants souffrant d'un cancer
à présent grégory vous avez toutes les
clés pour passer une soirée d'halloween
frissonnante il ne me reste plus qu'à
vous souhaiter une très bonne soirée
déguisée
merci manon avant la soirée déguisée
tout de même on va quand même regarder
votre reportage pendant les vacances
scolaires à lille de loisirs ski
équitation propose des stages l'occasion
pour les tout jeunes enfants de
découvrir les balades à poney regarder
je veux tenir le bleu tout le temps
d'accord
oriane trois ans et demi participent aux
stages d'équitation à lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines proposée
par l'association sky équitation cette
dernière permet de développer
l'équitation et de le rendre accessible
à tous
bombes sur la tête oriane est prête pour
faire sa première fois à poney
s'habituer à l'animal avoir de bons
réflexes
avant de débuter le stage julien le
moniteur apprend les bons gestes à
oriane avoir de sens
slalom petit trimballe temps de jeu pour
apprivoiser le poney c'est souvent la
première fois donc on a apprend un petit
peu comment se comporter autour du poney
à les familiariser avec l'animal et à
vaincre un petit peu leur première
appréhension
les premiers contacts avec l'animal et
ensuite c'est vraiment que du ludique on
leur apprend pas forcément de la
technique mais on leur apprend en
s'amusant en faisant des choses ludiques
comme m'a fait là le slalom le petit
train voilà durant ce stage
oriane a également découvert les
équipements et ça c'est très lourd c'est
la selle
je vais essayer de porter asie tout au
long de la séance l'enfant est très
demandeur et souhaitent interagir avec
le poney une vraie complicité s'est
créée pendant cette leçon une première
fois à poney réussi pour oriane c'est la
fin du journal à suivre l'émission 7,8
culture présentée par mélanie poquet
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]